so now that we have defined what a
Markov chain is what can we do with it
well we usually build malls in order to
predict some phenomenon of interest in
the case of a Markov chain there is
randomness and so it is natural to think
about making probabilistic
predictions for example going back again
to our checkout counter example you have
arrived at 6:45 p.m. there are two
customers in a queue and you want to
predict the number of customers in the
queue at 7 p.m.
assuming time steps are in seconds that
corresponds to 900 time steps later
there is no way to know exactly where
the system will be but you may be able
to give probabilistic prediction that is
to give the probability for the system
to be in a given State 900 time steps
later our main purpose will be to
calculate such probabilities a notation
will be useful here suppose that the
Markov chain of interest starts in a
given state I and that it runs for n
transitions letters introduced the
notation R IJ n to represent the N step
transition probability of adding in
state J this is the initial state I and
this is the definition R IJ of n first
note that these are probabilities given
that you story in AI after n steps you
will end up in some states with
probability 1 so the summation of all
our IJ of n for all possible state J
will be 1
and this is true for all I all initial
state I and for any time step and also
because we have a time invariant Markov
chain R IJ n is also given by this
formula here for any possible value of s
going from here to here plus s plus s in
other words if currently you are in
state I at time steps s and you're
interested in knowing what is the
probability of being in state J at time
n plus s which means n steps later you
will still have the same expression R IJ
n so how to calculate R IJ n for some
particular n this is easy for example
for our IJ of zero that means that are
no transition it will be either one if I
equal J and 0 otherwise
in one step in other words when N equals
1 our IGF 1 will be the priority
transition given by the Markov chain and
that is true for all I and og now let us
calculate R IJ n for N greater than or
equal to 2 we are going to apply the
total probability theorem and break up
the calculation of that quantity by
considering the different ways that the
event of interest can happen again the
event of interest is to go from AI state
I to state J in n time steps there are
many ways for that event to happen let's
group these many different ways as
follows let us consider the first n
minus 1 steps and group together all
possible ways of going from AI to a
state K a given state K in n minus 1
steps and this we go paths here
represent all possible ways of doing
that using the definition above that
probability of going from I to K in n
minus 1 steps will be R I K of n minus 1
now assuming that you ended up in state
K in n minus 1 transitions the
probability that you end up in state J
in the next transition is simply the
one-step transition probability P KJ
so all together the priority of going
from state I to state J in n steps and
in being in state K after n minus 1
steps is simply R I K and minus 1 times
P kg note that state K can be any of the
finite number of possible states of our
system in summary all such paths can be
represented by the following diagram so
again from time 0 to a time you're in
state I and you want to be at time n in
state J and you break down the all the
possible ways by first looking at what
would happen after step n minus 1 you
can be in state 1 state K all the way to
state M we have calculated these
expression here this is what we have
done here
this is for state one
and state him
so the overall probability of reaching
no J is obtained by an application of
the total probability theorem it gives
the following formula so this is
corresponding to the total probability
theorem here this is the calculation
that we have done here and we sum over
all possibilities for K where do we use
the Markov property in this calculation
well the key step here was when we said
that this probability year was pkg going
back to the calculation that we had here
this was in fact the probability of
being in state J at times n given you
started state I and you were in state n
minus 1 in K and that probability being
equal to the priority of xn equals J
given the last time that is due to the
Markov and this is
pkg this is the recursion in the
following sense assume that you have
calculated our I K n minus 1 for all
possible values of I and all possible
value of K and you had stored all these
values M square of them for any pair IJ
you can now calculate R IJ n using that
formula and you can do it in essentially
M multiplication and n minus 1 additions
that is in a number of steps or number
of elementary steps proportional to n
you do this for all M square pair of I G
at the time step n and then you repeat
for n plus 1 etc so this is the essence
of the recursion here is a variation
that is another recursion for computing
our G of n you start at I and suppose
that in a one time step you find
yourself in state K the priority here is
the one step transition ek Pik
and then given that you're in state K
what is the priority that you will end
up in state J in n minus 1 step will be
again looking at this formula that we
had here our KJ of n minus 1 again you
have to consider all possible values for
K here and the application of the troll
probability theorem gives the following
alternative recursion R IJ of n
the Sun for all K equals one to n of P I
K times R K G of n minus 1
these two recursion this one and this
one are different they are both valid
and could be useful depending on the
specific questions you may want to
answer finally note that if initial
state is itself random that is given by
a random distribution this is the
initial distribution on the state then
the state probability distribution after
n steps will be given by this formula
this is the state after n step is simply
that and this is yet again an
application of the total probability
theorem